واصلت قوته فاجنر انسحابها والعوده الى
قواعدها من مقاطعات روسيه بموجب وساطه قام
بها الرئيس البيلاروسي الكسندر لوكاشينكو
واوقفت التصعيد بين قائد المجموعه
والسلطات في موسكو وتنص تفاهمات على عدم
ملاحقه ومقاتليه بتهام الخيانه الا ان
القياده الروسيه ابقت مع ذلك على اجراءات
مكافحه الارهاب في العاصمه الروسيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما حيثيات وتفاصيل
التفاهمات التي جرت بين الجانبين وكيف
نقرا المشهد الذي انتهت اليه الازمه التي
اندلعت وسطا هناك روسيا في الحرب الدائره
باوكرانيا والى اي مدى اثرت الاحداث على
صوره روسيا وهل عكست صراعا داخليا على
السلطه والنفوذ وما احتمالات ان يتكرر هذا
المشهد ما الابعاد الخارجيه للازمه
والسيناريو التي انتهت اليه وهل ستلقي
بظلالها على سياسات موسكو في الصراع مع
الغرب ومسار الحرب في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
دخل الاتفاق الذي رعته بيلاروسيا حيز
التنفيذ وشرعت قوات فاجنر في الانسحاب من
المقاطعات التي انتشرت وسيطرت فيها على
منشات عسكريه مهمه على علاقه مباشره
باداره الحرب في اوكرانيا والى حين تستكمل
فاجنر انسحابها يبدو انها ستجر وراءها
اسئله عميقه وثقيله في اكثر من اتجاه ليس
اقلها اهميه الحيثيات التي اطلقت التصعيد
وحقيقه اوضاع السلطه في روسيا وتداعيات
هذا وذاك على مسارات الحرب في اوكرانيا
العاصمه الروسيه كانت على مرمى تحركات
فاجنر حتى قال زعيمها بريغوجين تجنبا لسفك
الدماء قررنا ونحن على بعد 200 كم من
موسكو اعاده مقاتلين الى قواعدهم في
المقابل اكد الكريم انه لن تتخذ اجراءات
قضائيه ضد المقاتلين الذين شاركوا في
التصعيد العسكري ما حدث داخل روسيا تردد
صدى بقوه في الجوار فقد اشدد الرئيس
الاوكراني فلودي على ان الفوضى تعم روسيا
ويجب سحب القوات الروسيه من اوكرانيا اما
وزير الخارجات الامريكيه انطوني بلينكن
فقد رجح استمرار الاضطرابات اسابيع في
روسيا مضيفا ان هناك تصدعات في السلطه
الروسيه الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
الذي ما كان للوساطه البيلاروسيه ان تنجح
دون ضوء اخضر منه اكد انه يعطي الاولويه
القصوى للعمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من باريس
الدكتور زياد ماجد واستاذ العلوم السياسيه
بالجامعه الامريكيه في باريس
استاذ السياسه الدوليه في جامعه بيرمنجه
سيد سكوت هذا التصعيد الذي وصلت
اصداؤه او بالفعل وصل الى تخوم العاصمه
الروسيه على بعد 200 كيلومتر من موسكو
انتهى بضمانات امنيه كيف تقرا حيثيات ما
جرى والى ما انتهى اليه
اولا
هذا ليس بالامر الذي حصل في وجهه خلال 24
ساعه فمنذ اسابيع بلوا حتى اشهر كان هناك
خلاف متطور متزايد بين مجموعه
بشكل خاص وقائد الغزو الاوكراني
وما حصل يوم امس انه بعد اسابيع من
الخطابات المتبادله وبعد طلب وزاره الدفاع
بان
يقوم مجموعه
تقديم الولاء للجيش احتج
بالسيطره على مدينه وذلك
وهو كان قد ساعه ايضا سيطره على مقر
القياده الجنوبيه دون اي طلقه وحقيقه ان
قوات الصيعت التقدم هكذا نحو موسكو كثير
من التساؤلات في العاصمه
ضعفا وعدم استعداد الان لدينا هذا الاتفاق
ولكن الاتفاق قصير المدى احيانا او الفتره
القصيره قد يكون ذلك
قد يكون في بيلاروسيا ليس بحاله
المنفى فقط لاحتوائه هو لديه شبكه قويه
جدا في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ويمكن
يواصل خلق المشاكل وحتى لو شرح احتواء على
الفتره القصيره فكيف يمكن لبوتين ان يسيطر
على الوضع محليا لماذا تصف هذا الاتفاق
بقصير المدى يعني الاتفاق تعدد او يتالف
من عده مراحل منها ان من لم يشارك في هذه
العمليه يستطيع ان ينضم الى وزاره الدفاع
ومن شارك في هذه العمليه لن يتحمل اي
مسؤوليه اجرائيه ولكن الى حد الان غير
واضح ما مصير من شارك هل سيخرج من البلاد
هل سيسلم الاس لحه بتقديرك لن تصمد هذه
التفاهمات
هناك الكثير من الشك فيما يتعلق بتفاصيل
هذا الاتفاق فعلى سبيل المثال كم عدد كم
عدد مرتزقه العداد حوالي 25 الف واكثر كم
منهم سيد وزاره الدفاع ويضمون للجيش
النظامي وهل سيحاولون ايضا الجيش قوه خاصه
وماذا يحسم الاسترجاع عمليات تقوم بها
خارج البلاد مثلا في الشرق الاوسط وحتى في
افريقيا وهل عمليات في غايه الربحيه
الماليه والاهم من ذلك هل
نسيتطبق كل البنوته الاتفاق هل سيبقى
هادئا ويتوقف عن انتقاد وزاره الدفاع
والدعوه لقاده وزير الدفاع لا نعرف ان كان
سيفعل ذلك ايضا كل ما لدينا لحد الان هو
مجرد فتره التنفس وراحه
بعد خطابه يوم السبت لم نشاهده بعد هذا
الاتفاق ولا نعرف حتى ان اين هو الان
حاليا وبالتالي هلا
فقط السيد البقيه روسيا وكيف تستعيد
شرعيه معلومه اخرى مهمه عندما غادر
المنتزه
هذه تلك المدينه لما
لم يخسروا
استهجان واللحب بهم المدير تلك كانوا فيها
رحمت بها رحب بهذا هؤلاء المرتزقه وليس
بالجيشه
روسيا وبالتالي هل يعتبر تحدي الكرملين
تعود اليك ولكن دعني اسمع رايي الدكتور
زياد
هل ما جرى كان مفاجئا السيد سكوت اشار الى
السياقات التي ادت الى ما جرى من انتقادات
كان يواجهها بشكل علني لوزير الدفاع
ولقائد الاركان ولكن هل كان من المتوقع ان
تصل الامور الى هذا الحد وكيف تقراون
التفاهمات التي جرت
لا انا اعتقد ان الامور مفاجئه في سرعتها
وفي منحه التمرد العسكري الذي اخذته ولو
انه ظل محدودا ولم يعمم على ارجاء واسعه
من البلاد لكن من الواضح ان ما جرى كان
تصعيدا كبيرا يظهر عدم قدره الدوله
المركزيه على فرض خطوتها وسيادتها الكامله
في بلد شاسع جغرافيا وكبير ديموغرافيا
يظهر ان ميليشيا نشات وترعرعت في كنف
السلطه انما ظلت متمايزه عن الجيش وعن
المؤسسات الامنيه الرسميه كان لها مصادر
دخل كبيره مرتبطه بالدوله ومرتبطه بعمليات
خارج الاراضي الروسيه شاركت في الحرب في
اوكرانيا بعد ان شاركت في سوريا وفي ليبيا
وفي عدد من البلدان الافريقيه وها هو
زعيمها بعد ان شتم وزير الداخليه واتهم
قياده الاركان بانهم مجموعه من الخونه
وتوعد بشنقهم في الساحه الحمراء يصل الى
وساطه مع رئيس دوله ويخرج بموجبها من دون
ان يعاقب لا على ما قاله ولا على تقدم
قواته واخذها مناطق من البلاد
وتحديدها
يعني الجانب الروسيه ردوا على ذلك بانه
اتم انهاء التصعيد في اقل من 24 ساعه ودون
سفك دماء دون اراقه يعني دماء شخص واحد في
روسيا الا يسجل ذلك للرئيس بوتين
وللواساطه التي قام بها الرئيس البالاروسي
لا لا اعتقد ان ذلك يسجل لهم لسبب انه
مجرد قيام هذا التمرد يظهر ضعفا في اداره
البلاد وقد يشجع انواع اخرى من التمرد في
مرحله لاحقه خاصه ان من قام بالتمرد لم
يتعرض لاي عقاب حتى الان على الاقل كما
انه في جبهه حلفاء روسيا اثار توترا او
نوعا من التنافس بين الرئيس في كازاخستان
الرئيس البيولوسي الذي نجحت وساطته قدرات
في منطقه الشيشان كان هناك صمت صيني واضح
وبوتين نفسه اضطر الى الظهور وتوعد من
يتمرد ثم جرى التراجع عن تهديداته بعد
نجاح الوساطه كان قبل هذا التمر د زعيما
مطلقا في روسيا او هكذا على الاقل برزت
الامور المؤسسات العسكريه والامنيه
استقطبت على معظم الموازنات واضعفت
وزاره الخارجيه مثل قطاعات اقتصاديه اما
تعرضت لعقوبات او لم تعد اولويه روسيه
بسبب الحرب
وتمسكت السلطه في مرحله معينه وها قد بدات
تظهر بعد العلامات لا تعني عفوا جذريا
لبوتين لكن صورته كحاكم مطلق تعرضت
للاهتزاز ولم تعد التراشقات بتهم بين
فاجنر ووزاره الداخليه فقط انما طالته
مباشره هذه المره وظهرت له
اشرت الى انواع اخرى من التمرد قد يشجعها
ما قام به
يعني عن ماذا تتحدث بالتحديد الى ماذا
تؤشر
ربما يكون هناك الان اضافه الى الميليشيات
وهذا بحد ذاته يعني عدم احتكار العنف كما
يقال في بنى الدوله اضافه الى وجود
ميليشيات اخرى بالمناسبه غير في سوريا في
عفوا في روسيا تملك اسلحه واعتاد عسكري
وتضم اما سجناء سابقين او اشخاص مجندين
كمرتزقه اضافه الى وجود ذلك هناك ضمن
المؤسسات الامنيه والعسكريه من يكون الان
تزداد شقوفه بقد
ره التي يتحول الى مستنقع لم يعد الحسم
فيها ممكنا اما تصعيد اضافي في العمليات
العسكريه وهذا يتطلب موارد بشريه وماليه
قد يكون من الصعب توفيرها وليس صدفه ان
بوتين نفسه اشار اليوم الى احتمال تجنيد
مسجونين بتهم جنائيه مقابل تخفيف عقوباتهم
او الافراج عنهم على الاتفاق بالامس
وهناك مراكز قوى يمكن ان تصبح اكثر طموحا
في السياسه وتعتبر ان ضعف بوتين هو مناسبه
لاظهار طموحها او على الاقل لفرد شروط ما
ترتبط بالحرب تصعيدا او تسوية وهذا يترك
ايضا مجالا لمخابرات اجنبيه للبحث
عن تواصل مع من يمكن تشجيعه على انهاء
الحرب او على اضعاف السلطه المركزيه
ولكن اكثر من نقطه لابد من التوقف عندها
دعني اعود الى السيده سكوت لوكا السيد
اسكت طيب هنالك نظريه تقول بان ما جرى
انما كان معدل سلفا ومخطط له من اجل
الانتهاء من
فاقنر وقواتها واخراج بريكوجن من الصوره
بالاتفاق مع بريجوجن نفسه هذا الاحتمال ما
امكانيه ان يكون قائما بقوه
في مثل هذه الاوقات وخاصه بسرعه الاحداث
التي نشادها دائما تحفر كثير من نظريات
ونظريات المؤامره وبالتالي في نظريه
المؤامره بان الغرب هو خلف والتمر
هذا الدليل عليه وليس هناك دليل بان هذا
عمل نظمه وارتفق عليه سيد فوتين مع سيد
بيولوجيا لابعاد الجميع
نعود دعونا نعود الاساسيات
نعلم ومنذ اشهر ان السيد
كان ينتقد بشكل وزاره الدفاع وحتى عندما
كانت قواته تتولى قياده الهجوم بمحاوله
السيطره على مدينه
وان نعلم عندما استولوا على تلك المدينه
لاحقا بعد سته اشهر من الهجمات من قبل
ومجموعه قال السيد قال بان ساسحب قواتي
ويمكن للطرف اخر ان
يسيطر هذا واتهم قوات ادريسنا بقصف قواته
وايضا كان قبل ذلك يتهم وزاره الدفاع
بالكذب بالكذب حوض الهجوم المضاد
الاوكراني وذلك لتقليم شان النجاحات
الاوكرانيه ولتقليل عدد الضحايا روسيا
وايضا نعلم من عده مصادر وهذا امر ظهر
واكدته مصادر الاستخباريه مثل الامريكيه
ان السيد
قبل حوالي عشره ايام بانه سيقوم باطلاق
هذه العمليه
وبناء على ابسط التفسيرات والحقائق هو
الصراع على السلطه على النفوذ وليس صراع
لحل محل بوتين بل هو محاوله مسيد برغي
جنديكن هو المستشار اكثر اهميه
ولا اعتقد ان هذا القتال وهذه المنافسه قد
انتهت طيب عندما تتحدث
عم تتحدث عن صراع على السلطه صراع على
السلطه بين من ومن
نعم هذا هذا طبعا بين سيد مقابل وزير
الدفاع السيد شوقر وفي هذا الوقت القائد
العام
للغزو الاوكراني الروسي على اوكرانيا
وايضا الامر كلها بدا في الصيف الماضي عند
بدا بوتين يستخدم مجموعه فاكنار
لقذافه وبينما السيد شوقر وزير الدفاع كان
استقامه قد قوته ولا قلت سيد جن واحد
القاده السابقين للغزو في الواقع هو رقم
اثنين نائب مجموع رئيسه مجموعه ذاتنار
وبالتالي في بدء هذه السنه السيد الدفاع
واخرون من وزاره الدفاع
وكانوا يفضلون
السيده الينا سوبانينا المحلله السياسيه
سيده ايلينا سوبولينا يعني يجمع الضيفين
هنا في الاستوديو السيد ماجد والسيد سكوت
لوكاس على ان ما جرى انما يصيب صوره روسيا
بتصدع وانما يدلل على صراع على صراع في
السلطه داخل روسيا كيف تردون على ذلك
مساء الخير انا بصراحه
استطيع ان اتفق على بعض النقاط لانه
الصراعات وتصدعات يبدو هي موجوده
وتمرد
هو فيه صبغه اصطناعيه نوعا ما نعم مبدا
الاساسي كان وما زال العداله الاجتماعيه
ولكن هي كواجهه اما ما هو عن اشياء مخفيه
في هذه المسيره او في هذا التمرد انا
متاكده انه هناك سرعات ما بين مجموعات
مختلفه
وهذا الشيء ليست له حتى علاقه
بالعمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا اما هذا
الشيء له علاقه
بالانتخابات الرئيسيه
يعني وعندما تتحدثين عن صراعات بين
مجموعات مختلفه من تقصدين وعلى اي مستوى
ومن هم هؤلاء
اكيد انه
هو كان مدعوم وهذا الدعم ادى لهذا التوافق
بهذه الضمانات نحن لا نعرف الاسماء
بالتاكيد ولكن نعرف المطلب الاساسي لسيد
بريجوجل وهي اقاله وزير الدفاع
السيد شرقي هو سياسي مخضرم وكان يعتبر وما
زال يعتبر من قبل بعض الناس خليفه رقم
الاول للرئيس بوتين فيما بعد اكيد فيما
بعد نحن لا نتحدث عن الان لا نتحدث حتى عن
سنه 2024 ولكن هو سمي اكثر من مره بهذا
اللقب فاذا كما يبدو هناك مجموعات لا تريد
ان تروا في هذا المنص
ب كخليفه اذا صح التعبير وهناك مجموعات
اخرى حابه
دور هذا طيب يعني يصب ذلك في مصلحه الرئيس
بوتين
بمعنى ان ما يمكن ان يخلفه او من يمتلك
سلطه ودعم من جهات معينه اليوم يتم الحديث
على انه ستتم ازالته وهو وزير الدفاع
هذه الحاله بحد ذاتها هي حاله ليست جيده
التمرد المسلح هذا ليس جيده واعطاء ضمانات
وهذا لو عفو وايضا
هذه هذه الاعفاء هذه الطريقه لسيد بريكوجن
ايضا كل هذا غريب جدا هل
سيخفض هذا شعبيه رئيس بوتين قليلا يمكن
انا اتفق مع ذلك ولكن ليس كثيرا لماذا احد
انه غريب له مواطنين روسيا
بالطبع يعني انا ذكرت ان هذا التمرد الذي
جرى ومشاهده الاجهزه الروسيه مقبله على
صدمات داخليه يشجع اطراف خارجيه على
الدخول في مفاوضات على من يمكن ان يلعب
دورا لفهم الواقع اكثر للتاثير في الواقع
لكن هناك بلا شك خشيه عالميه وليس فقط
غربيه من اللا استقرار في روسيا لانها بلد
نووي لان فيها منشات عسكريه خطيره جدا
لانه من المفيد ان يبقى هناك سلطه مركزيه
يمكن التفاوض معها لكن بلا شك مشهد التصدع
بدا واضحا وليست ما جرت من تسويات نهايه
المطاف لان هناك الكثير من الغموض حول
مصير الالاف من المقاتلين هل سيعودون الى
الجبهات ام لا ما هي مراكز تمركزهم
الجديده
يلعب دورا في بين الفيزا لاداره بعض
التنافس القائم ما مصير وزير الدفاع وهو
اولا ليس عسكريا لكنه ايضا سياسي له دور
وشان كما تفضلت ضيفتكم يعتبر من المحتملين
في خلافه بوتين رئاسه الاركان وموقعها
منذ الامس ولم نسمع منه ولا من قائد
الاركان اريد ان اسمع من السيد سكوت لوكا
سيد سكوت ما جرى لم ياتي في سياقنا منعزل
بل ياتي فيما الحرب الروسيه داخل اوكرانيا
متواصله كيف يمكن ان ينعكس ما جرى على هذه
الحرب هل سينعكس تصعيدا ام ام على العكس
باختصار لو سمحت
ان صديقنا في موسكو قدمتنا مفيدا جدا
اليوم حول ما قد يحصل لاحقا على الاقل من
قبل السيد بوتين وايضا اعطتنا فكرتين
مهمتين الاولويه لن تكون على الحرب في
اوكرانيا الاولويه الاولى ستكون لتاسيسه
وايجاد منهم اعداء الدوله والالقاء لهم
على اخرين اضافه رصيد
وهذا التكتيك لم استخدمه السابقا وفي
روسيا ويمكن استخدم الان في وقت الحرب
وايضا هناك شيء اخر مهم هو عندما تسالت
حول اعطاء او تتساءلت حول العفو عن السيد
وهذا يعني نسيت ربما
ولكن للاسف انتهى وقت هذا البرنامج استاذه
السياسه الدوليه في جامعه بيرمن هام شكرا
لك دكتور زياد ماجد استاذ العلوم السياسيه
بالجامعه الامريكيه في باريس الشكر لك
ايضا
ولالينا المحلله السياسيه من موسكو
نهايه ما وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]